we did learn this morning that there has
been a really really bad train crash in
New Jersey at last check one person is
dead and over a hundred people have been
injured when a New Jersey Transit
commuter train crashed into the Hoboken
station this morning New Jersey's
emergency management system is reporting
that more than a hundred people have
been injured one person that so far
found dead federal investigators are
enroute the National Transportation
Safety Board is gathering information
this hugely damaged the Hoboken Terminal
building
I actually have a lot to say about this
and we don't yet have all the details
about this particular crash it appears
as though the train was moving very
quickly at least two quickly given that
it was already in the station you might
have seen if you've traveled on trains
that at the end of lines you often have
what sort of look like bumpers and
they're meant to stop the train if it's
going too fast those only work up to a
certain speed and a friend of mine who
works for Amtrak it's not a high-speed I
think he said it's something like it's a
five or ten mile mile per hour bumper if
you think about the mass of a train
those bumpers are not going to be able
to prevent the train going 20 25 or 30
miles an hour from getting through
necessarily it appears as though
although the train did hit the bumper it
was going far too fast for the bumper to
keep the train contained it went off the
tracks and did major major damage to the
station we're still trying to figure out
exactly what happened here we don't know
if the train engineer passed out fell
asleep was otherwise incapacitated
trains have a 60 second alert er which
requires the train operator to within 60
seconds every 60 seconds they have to
press something in the train to show hey
I'm still with it I'm still here if they
don't the Train will immediately slow
down the problem is that still allows
for nearly two minutes if you pass out
or otherwise leave the the locomotive or
or are incapacitated right after turning
off the alert ER you have 60 full
seconds before the train will start to
break and then because it's not
the most aggressive braking system it
can take depending on the speed of the
train at the time that the automatic
braking engages anywhere from thirty to
sixty additional seconds for the train
to stop so we're talking about even with
the system working the way it's designed
ninety to a hundred and twenty seconds
of potentially unsupervised train
operation this gets to the broader
problem with American trains and you've
heard me talk about this many times
before number one we have this general
issue in the US where because of the
fossil fuel lobby the airline lobby and
the automobile lobby it is very
difficult to make progress on train
development we recently saw
Massachusetts based bus company Peter
Pan actively lobbied to block a study
into train service across Massachusetts
why well that's their bread and butter
they run something like 10 or so buses a
day back and forth across the
Massachusetts Turnpike if all of a
sudden you've got train service for that
route not subject to surface traffic
quite common on i-90 the Massachusetts
Turnpike it'll be bad bad for the bus
companies and this applies to short
airline flights this applies to people
driving etc in addition to that because
we also have lacked this advancement in
train development we are missing some of
the systems that other trains in other
parts of the world have for example
forget about the 60-second alerter
the maximum speed at any given point on
the track is controlled by a computer
meaning that aside from this alerter
there would be no way if we had a system
that said once you are within I don't
know what distance it would be call it
half a mile of Hoboken station the train
can't be going 30 miles per hour by that
point the computer has already slowed
the train down to 20 or 15 or whatever
the case may be so this really exposes
just how antiquated and retrograde the
United States is when it comes to train
technology in so many ways we could have
a conversation about infrastructure this
is also a conversation about lobbies
this is a conversation about how far
the US as a first world country is in
many areas including train travel
ultimately we are going to learn the
details of this particular crash we will
figure out well what happened to the
train engineer what was there any other
safety system in place which did not
work properly or which was not triggered
we'll learn about all that but we also
have to stay take a step back from it
and it doesn't reduce or increase the
tragic nature of this casualty and the
hundred plus people that were killed but
we have to take a step back and say hey
what is going on with trains in the
United States and it's really not good
ok let's take a break we are on reddit
you can go to david pakman.com slash
reddit re d di t join the discussion
many new topics every day on our reddit
discussion forum you can suggest
interviews there you can suggest stories
always great to hear from people there
after the break I think a lot of people
are going to find this conversation
interesting but maybe surprising we will
be speaking to Elizabeth's or wolle
about the fastest growing group of
incarcerated individuals what group is
it well we'll talk about that next
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30 day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s